everything I do comes from seeing
patients and not having an answer for
how to help them right now all of us are
using mobile technologies and computers
for typing and texting and sending
messages generating language folks with
locked-in syndrome don't have any way to
do that we had brain damaged I don't
think I'll ever be able to do this and
dr. Molly said it is rewiring his brain
he'll be able to do it it was astounding
to me it will be real fun to see where
this goes
it's almost a science fiction when the
phone rang at eight o'clock in the
morning and it was the hospital and they
told me and he was to get there right
away they found out it was a brain stem
major stroke
Gregory lost his speech he lost the use
of his body limbs he was instantly
paralyzed his reach was taken and and we
were given that it was locked-in
syndrome and I had no never heard of it
didn't know anything about it and I
remember leaving the hospital of that
day not understanding at all but
thinking that Greg's body was dead but
his brain was alive and how
horrific that was I am 100% dependent on
my caregivers I am bathed I have range
of motion I am dressed I have to have
finished with my breakfast and wait 2
hours before I can be laid down for
range of motion or any physical movement
I'm physically put into my wheelchair
with a Hoyer lift and my caregivers help
I am a tube feeder no liquid or food
enters my mouth I would be at risk of
getting aspiration pneumonia it
frustrates me when people ignore me I
may have something to say and they will
not look me in the face or ask me if I
have something I want to say it
frustrates me when people act like I am
deaf they talk around me to each other
but not to me
they don't include me in on the
conversations it frustrates me when
people ask the people around me
questions that I can answer as if I
weren't there
my name is dr. Melanie freed Okin I am a
professor at Oregon Health and Science
University in Portland Oregon so we do
have a full agenda for the hour today
mostly something from every team so
let's start with software and look at
pivotal tracker our team is unique we
have four different teams that together
have worked for 12 years to develop our
non-invasive brain computer interface I
am a speech-language pathologist I work
primarily on our brain computer
interface research projects our brain
computer interface technology is
primarily aimed at people with very
severe disabilities locked-in syndrome
is a term that we use to describe
someone who is essentially locked into
his or her body the kind of classic form
of locked-in syndrome involves only eye
movement or blinking but there's also
complete lis where the person has lost
all of their voluntary motor function so
even the ability to blink or to move the
eyes is is lost if you have no voluntary
motor function you have no way to
communicate with another human being so
that's the the gap that we're trying to
fill a lot of the brain computer
interface work is being done in
engineering labs or neuroscience labs
with graduate students and researchers
and has not been tried we take our work
out into the community and we work with
many individuals with severe
disabilities
hey there Greg it's nice to see you
doing well today
good good to hear it brain computer
interface allows someone to control the
computer just using only their
brainwaves in our system we have an
electrode cap that holds electrodes
against the scalp and they can watch
what the system is presenting to them
lift his head up a little bit so that I
can slide the cap on okay are you ready
to go okay so it'll be this is fun here
we go there's one letter presented at a
time in the middle of the screen so it's
just flash flash flash letter letter
letter you're watching that stream of
letters go by and when you see the
letter you want you have that
involuntary brain responsive yes that
one instead of someone moving their hand
to press the letter M they're looking at
a screen and when they see the letter M
they get a special brainwave a surprise
brainwave that's called the p300 and
that p300 brainwave is being taken as
their keystroke I have tested various
programs created by the engineers of
computer programmers to see if they are
computer friendly for people like me the
exercises I do on the computer are
challenging and I like being challenged
[Music]
all right nice job that's awesome the
kind of general wisdom in the BCI field
right now is that it typically works for
healthy users under controlled
situations you know our RS to be
keyboard works reliably for most healthy
people who try it but when we take it
out into the field it's less likely to
work
[Music]
the pie-in-the-sky you know the dream
goal for a brain-computer interface
would be to allow people with severe
disabilities and and communication
impairments to communicate in real-time
that's really not possible with any kind
of assistive technology for
communication at this point obviously we
want to make it faster and make it
better that's what we're working towards
but the first goal is to make it work
consistently and reliably for the people
who need it I have had people be fearful
to approach me I would want them to know
that I'm not contagious I would want
them to know it's okay to approach me
and talk I would want them to know I
have a sense of humor I would want
people to never have to experience what
I go through daily locked-in syndrome is
not for sissies I am excited to be on
board for whatever this new technology
takes us I'm happy to be part of the
team
you
you